deux allers retours de livres carlier
n'était possible à liverpool parce que
le métro mots assez pas facile vous
pouvez pas faire et les sinistrés sont
venus crier leur ras-le-bol
tous habitent on travaille dans le bourg
de rivière pilote qui a subi une énième
inondations la semaine dernière ils
espèrent des solutions depuis longtemps
et viennent demander des actions
concrètes au maire qui acceptent de les
recevoir
pour l'instant c'est que départ moi
j'avais des actions depuis longtemps on
promet on promet en promet et on n'a pas
d'actions
donc maintenant action raymond théodose
leur exposé le plan d'action qu'il a
élaborées depuis son arrivée notamment
un aménagement de palplanches sur les
berges des deux rivières et la mise en
place de zones de rétention d'eau en cas
de crue le maire a par ailleurs organisé
une réunion le 12 novembre avec tous les
services concernés des rochers au fait
et au à messia bus est vraisembablement
tous les services de l'état que tourner
autour l'adn la police de l'eau et je
vais dans un petit moment fait en sorte
que la
commission de l'espace une soit aussi
présente
et puis bien sûr les avilit si tous sont
conscients de la nécessité d'un plan
d'action à long terme
ils attendent aussi des solutions à
court terme dans ce magasin un système
de portes étanches a bien fonctionné
l'association des commerçants demandent
une aide à l'équipement
le coût est inférieur aux pertes causées
par les inondations